déprimé et en détresse et le ressenti du
personnel soignant de l'hôpital puerta
de hierro à madrid
soixante huit jours après le début du
confinement en espagne les médecins en
unité de soins intensifs tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
le traumatisme de deux mois de travail
dans le service qu'ovide 19 commence à
les rattraper
l'adrénaline du moment le stress du
moment nous ont permis de rester en vie
de travail et maintenant que cela fait
deux mois nous commençons à nous sentir
un peu déprimé en détresse nous
commençons à ressentir le stress
accumulé certaines personnes commencent
à se sentir un peu déprimé angoissé
c'est maintenant que nous commençons à
ressentir les conséquences de ce que
nous avons vécu il ya deux mois
désormais les soignants ockrent une
deuxième vague de contamination une
résurgence de l'épidémie qui serait
dramatique car l'hôpital a commencé à
traiter les cas non liés aux coronavirus
dans son unité de soins intensifs
si nous commençons à sortir maintenant
et que nous ne faisons pas de manière
responsable
si nous sortons avec trop d'enthousiasmé
que nous nous réunissons hainaut
mélangeons il y aura probablement un
rebondissement et cela nous arrivera au
mauvais moment parce que nous ne sommes
pas seulement fatigué l'hôpital revient
à la normale et nous ne traitons pas
seulement des patients atteints de
corona virus mais aussi les passions
normaux et il est plein l'hôpital est
plein de ces deux types de patients
il n'y a pas de liste ils gagnent
deuxième bague maintenant comme au début
nous devrons déplacer les autres
patients pour acculer si tous les
patients atteints de corona virus et ce
sera nouveau une situation dramatique
une détresse partagé par la population
espagnole qui elle demande un
déconfinement plus rapide depuis
plusieurs jours des manifestations
s'organisent avec des concerts de
casseroles improvisé les citoyens
dénoncent la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement l'accusant
de limiter les libertés et s'irrite du
contraste avec leurs voisins européens